let's just put a pause on that and take
you straight to liverpool where we are
expecting to hear from merseyside police
following that fatal stabbing of the
nine-year-old girl
i'm going to hand you over to chief
constable serena kennedy and detective
chief superintendent mark comey news
head of investigations
good afternoon
a nine-year-old girl who we can name
today as olivia pratt corbell has died
following a shooting in dovecot last
night monday the 22nd of august
and her family are absolutely devastated
inconsolable and heartbroken
i know that the murder of olivia has
rocked our communities
who are quite rightly
upset
and outraged that such an abhorrent
crime has occurred here on the streets
of merseyside
the people of liverpool and merseyside
are known for their compassion and
pulling together in times of crisis
and i know that our communities
people are wanting to help the family in
any way possible
this is not the time for anyone who
knows who is responsible for this
shooting to remain tight-lipped
it is time for our communities to come
together
with us
and make merseyside a place where the
use of guns on our streets is totally
unacceptable
and those who use them are held to
account
our thoughts and condolences are with
olivia's family
who have been torn apart
no mom
no dad
no sister or brother should ever have to
experience loss in this way
poignantly olivia was killed on the 15th
anniversary of the murder of rhys jones
murder should have been a watershed
moment in the battle against gun crime
and the use of guns on our streets
but shockingly there are still callous
criminals
who are prepared to use weapons on our
streets
and have utter disregard for the
heartache and the pain that they have
caused to olivia's family
olivia's family are the third family
who've lost a loved one in the past week
through gun crime
following the tragic murders of sam
river and ashley dale
our thoughts very much remain with their
families and the investigations continue
into their murders
at 10 pm last night our officers were
called to olivia's home on king's heath
avenue and when we arrived we found
three people who'd been injured
including olivia
and her mum
it is believed that one of the injured
parties a 35 year old man was being
chased by a man armed with a gun he was
firing at him
the man being chased forced his way into
olivia's house
and the offender ran in after him
firing a number of shots with complete
disregard for olivia and her family
who had no connection with the gunman or
the man who fought his way in
sadly olivia was fatally wounded when
the gunman fired at the man who was
trying to get into the house
and her mum also suffered a gunshot to
her wrist
the first 35 year old man had been
chased suffered a number of gunshots to
his upper body
whilst olivia lay dying
he was picked up by his friends who took
him to hospital
on arrival our officers could see just
how poorly olivia was
and they rushed her to alderhay
children's hospital where despite the
best efforts of medical staff
she sadly died
and her mum was taken to hospital by
colleagues from the northwest ambulance
service
this is a shocking and appalling attack
which will reverberate around our
communities
and i want to take this opportunity
again to appeal to anybody who knows who
is responsible for this attack to please
come forward and give us those names
we need to find all who are responsible
for this
not just the gunman we need to find out
who supplied the weapon and who arranged
this terrible incident
forensic experts at the scene at this
moment in time conducting house to house
inquiries
have taken place and officers are
reviewing cctv footage
to establish and identify who is
responsible
we will not rest until those who are
responsible are put behind bars
i can guarantee that no stone will be
left unturned
i recognise how incredibly frightening
this is for our communities as well as
as well as the other murders that we've
seen this week at the hands of firearms
people will see a significant increase
in the number of police officers on the
streets of merseyside over the next
coming days we are being supported by
offices from across the northwest
including detectives
as you would expect we all already do a
tremendous amount to tackle gun crime
with our partners
which has reduced significantly over the
past two years
but this work with partners will
continue and i am meeting with our
partners this afternoon across the
region to discuss how we continue this
work
our investigation will rely heavily on
information from the members of the
public
and i urge the local community who have
any information who could help us to
come forward so we can bring those who
are responsible to justice
i also want to take the opportunity to
appeal to members of the criminal
fraternity and ask them to examine their
consciences
as they will have vital information that
can help us
the killing of a nine-year-old child is
an absolute tragedy and crosses every
single boundary and i would urge them to
do the right thing so we can put this
person behind bars
i will now hand you over to chief
superintendent mark comey
thank you chief
good afternoon
just a little more detail than do that
which has been provided by the chief
constable thus far
as the chief constable just said
detectives are currently investigating
this abhorrent murder of a nine-year-old
child olivia pratt corbell in dovecot
last night
my intention now is just go through a
little bit more detail around what we
know at this very early stage of the
investigation
following detectives working throughout
this last night we now believe that
around 10 pm
two men were walking along kings heath
avenue from the direction of finch lane
at that time they were approached
by a lone person
potentially a male
who was wearing a black padded jacket
a black balaclava with a peak
dark pants
and black gloves
this individual was approximately five
foot seven inch tall
and of slim build
and they were carrying a handgun
from what we now know from the review of
some cctv that we have acquired so far
we know that this person shot
at the two men who were walking down
kings heath avenue
both men responded by running away from
that person with a firearm
responding to the sounds of those
gunshots olivia's mum cheryl
appears to have opened the door to her
property
in order to see what was going on
outside
one of the men
the man that the chief constable
referred to is the 35 year old man
appears to have
seen the door opening and run towards
the opening of that door
he has then forced his way into the
property despite the very best efforts
of cheryl
and has made his way inside
as that was taking place
the person with the gun
has followed the mail to this property
that person has also tried to force
entry to the property
and as managed it would appear
to put their hand through the open door
as cheryl continues to try and close it
a shot has been fired
which we believe has hit cheryl
injuring her
and then fatally
wounding
olivia
olivia at that time we believe was stood
directly behind cheryl
that horrific circumstances the attacker
has continued the assault
and has continued to try and gain entry
to the property
and in doing so has then fired two
further shots at the 35 year old man who
is at this point inside cheryl and
olivia's home address
the attacker has then left
the front door
and has made off on foot
as the chief constable mentioned a few
moments ago
a dark audi coloured motor vehicle was
then seen to arrive at cheryl's home
address
and collect the 35 year old man
who at that point
was wounded and at the front of the
property
that vehicle we know then took the 35
year old male to hospital
i can confirm that that vehicle has now
been seized
cheryl was also taken to aintree
hospital and she is being treated for a
gunshot wound to her arm
olivia was taken to alderhay hospital
and as the chief constable has already
explained and as we know now
sadly succumbed to those injuries
despite the very best efforts of medical
staff police officers at the scene and
all the staff at alder hey children's
hospital
i can reassure you and all the people
listening and members of our community
that we have an incredibly experienced
team of detectives
now engaged on this inquiry
they are going to be working tirelessly
and we're doing last night throughout
the evening around this investigation
and we are absolutely committed to
finding the person responsible and
everybody connected with this offence as
the chief constable has already
pointed out
to do that
i need the public's help
and unfortunately this is not the first
time i've made an appeal this week
around a fatal homicide relating to
firearms
firstly
my appeal is to the person responsible
for this horrendous attack
on a nine-year-old school girl
to recognize the pain and anguish
that this has caused her family
i want that individual to hand
themselves in
i also want the second man that was in
the street that was with the 35 year old
man
to hand himself into us or make himself
known to us
a general appeal now
the local communities i've said before
earlier this week are absolutely
eyes and ears
of our intelligence and will help us
solve this horrific crime
therefore i need them to work with us
and provide to us any information at all
regarding who is responsible
their current location
the whereabouts of the weapon that was
used
or indeed any other information that
provides us with a full understanding of
what's taken place and allows us to
successfully prosecute those responsible
for this awful crime
i am interested of course in cctv
and that could be from private cctv at
people's homes
or if you have it for your doorbells
or dashcam footage
we have launched a major incident portal
on our website
and that information can be uploaded
directly to us
i'm also interested in any information
or speculation that people hear we know
that names will be circulated in the
communities
very quickly around those that are
responsible
i want to hear about those things
i also want to hear even if you were in
the area but you don't think you've
heard or seen anything
let us be the judge of that
so if you're in that area
or the surrounding community area please
make contact with us
speak to a detective and we will decide
whether you have any vital information
or not
i also want to know the whereabouts
leading up to
this attack of the black audi motor
vehicle that was used to convey the 35
year old man's hospital
all the information that we do receive
as you can imagine will be treated
with absolute confidence
we'll do everything to protect those
people who do come forward with
information if people feel that they
can't provide that then there is the
option around crime stoppers
and the links are on our website
or the contact number is oh 800
555
one one one
it is absolutely critical as the chief
constable has already mentioned that
this individual and everybody
surrounding this crime is identified and
swiftly brought to justice they have no
place in our communities
we have dealt with
a number of previous farms related
homicides
over this past week and now we are faced
with dealing one of a nine-year-old
child
thank you
[Applause]
you
[Applause]
this is sky news at one o'clock we've
just been hearing from merseyside police
the person you just heard from there is
detective chief superintendent mark
carmen who's head of investigations at
merseyside police speaking there giving
us details setting out the scene of how
the tragedy unfolded last night
following that fatal shooting of the
nine-year-old girl who has just been
named as olivia corbell there for us
let's just go live now straight to our
correspondent fraser maude who's at the
scene for us and fraser we've just been
learning there the name of the
nine-year-old girl who was shot dead
yesterday police they're just confirming
her name as olivia corbell and we heard
some horrific details from the police
there regarding the suspects and how
this tragedy unfolded
absolutely every description that was
given there by detective chief inspector
mark comey was
like something akin to a hollywood film
or a television
police drama two men walking down the
road not far from here approached by a
third man wearing the black outfit black
jacket black trousers black gloves and a
black balaclava approached them in the
streets began to fire shots at them and
chased them it was then that olivia
placabel's mother
cheryl opened the door to see what the
commotion was the man who was being
chased or one of the two men who was
being chased forced his way into the
property cheryl couldn't stop him as he
came into the property so too the gunman
tried to force entry and as he was
forcing entry lent through pushed his
hand through the door and fired a shot
and police believe or seemed to believe
at the moment that it was a single shot
that injured
cheryl black cabell's hand and then
passed through her and into the chest of
nine-year-old olivia who obviously then
needed serious medical attention the
next people to arrive though not the
paramedics the man who was with the man
who had been shot at a 35 year old man
who forced his way into the property his
accomplice or his friend
appeared in a dark-colored audi car
helped his friend into the car took him
to hospital leaving olivia's mother
seriously injured to her hand and olivia
left her dying on the floor paramedics
came to the scene they took olivia to
order her children's hospital they took
her mother to nearby entering hospitals
and retreated for her gunshot wound but
sadly medics at alder hey children's
hospital and even unable to save
nine-year-old olivia this is an
horrendous crime like something out of a
film as i say it's unbelievable scenes
that took place here last night a man
being chased by a gunman suggests that
this was a targeted attack olivia and
her mother simply caught in the
crossfire the wrong place at the wrong
time opening her door at a time when a
man fleeing a gunman saw that as his
opportunity to escape he's now being
treated in hospital for his gunshot
wounds after the gunman initially shot
at him in the street then fired two
further shots at him once he was in at
olivia's house before the gunman then
made his escape
on foot the police say that this is the
third firearms related
murder this week they are appealing for
the public to come forward they say that
the public are going to be their eyes
and ears the public should search their
consciences
because someone out there must know who
these people are they must know who the
man who was being chased once or why he
was being chased they must know the
gunman someone will know who this man is
and police say that it's their
responsibility to come forward part of
the community be part of a community
and give the information to the police
as quickly as possible people are also
asked if they have cctv footage either
from dash cams in their car or from
smart doorbells or from cctv cameras in
their houses to go to a secure portal on
the merseyside police website and upload
that information they're asking anyone
who was even in the area at all
regardless of whether they saw anything
or heard anything to get in touch and
give police any information tell them
what their whereabouts were what time
they were in this area so that police
can begin to piece together
an entire picture as to what was
happening around about 10 o'clock last
night this is a community that's in
shock it's a community where the
children play together in the streets
large families living in several
properties next door to each other this
is not a community where people grow up
and move away people who are born here
tend to stay here and they form very
very close bonds with others in the
community it seems as though this if
this was a targeted attack it was
targeted as a man who had nothing at all
to do with olivia or her mother they
were simply innocent victims innocent
bystanders caught in the wrong place in
the wrong time in what seems to be a
targeted attack very similar to an
attack just a mile and a half away from
here ashley dale shot and killed in her
own garden again when a gunman forced
entry into her property she wasn't the
target of the attack it's unclear who
was
and she was shot as she tried to escape
police are saying that this gun crime
cannot be allowed to continue the irony
and the poignancy of the of the attack
that killed olivia 15 years to the day
since reese jones was killed in the
croxters park area of liverpool shot
down as he returned home from a game of
football again caught in the crossfire
not the intended victim of the shooting
but again a young person losing their
lives for 15 years now police and the
local council local groups
all the local authorities trying to work
together several agencies working hand
in hand trying to reduce gun crime
trying to reduce knife knife crime in
the city of liverpool and here we are 15
years after the death of rhys jones an
11 year old boy shot in a park when he
was returning from football now a
nine-year-old girl olivia platt corbin
shot to death shot in the chest in her
own home as she was getting ready for
bed simply because her mother opened the
door to see what was going on outside
when there were guns when there was
gunfire
and a serious commotion police say
someone knows what happened someone
knows who carried out this horrendous
attack and they're urging those people
to get in touch with them as quickly as
they possibly can fraser thank you
absolutely gruesome details though as
fraser was just saying there um new
details have emerged of how a man
entered the house that olivia pratt cole
bell was in yesterday merseyside police
of course have been speaking to us a
short time ago we heard earlier from
chief constable serena kennedy who
described the situation as shocking and
appalling attack which will reverberate
around our community she confirmed of
course yesterday that the police were
called to olivia's home at around 10
o'clock yesterday night let's have a
listen to what she said earlier
at 10 pm last night our officers were
called to olivia's home on kingsmooth
avenue
and when we arrived we found three
people had been injured
including olivia
and her mum
it is believed that one of the injured
parties a 35 year old man was being
chased by a man armed with a gun he was
firing at him
the man being chased forced his way into
olivia's house
and the offender ran in after him
firing a number of shots
with complete disregard for olivia and
her family who had no connection with
the gunman or the man who fought his way
in
sadly olivia was fatally wounded when
the gunman fired at the man who was
trying to get into the house
and her mum also suffered a gunshot to
her wrist
the first 35 year old man had been
chased suffered a number of gunshots to
his upper body
olivia lay dying
he was picked up by his friends who took
him to hospital
on arrival our offices could see just
how poorly olivia was
and they rushed her to alderhay
children's hospital where despite the
best efforts of medical staff
she sadly died
and her mum was taken to hospital by
colleagues from the northwest ambulance
service
this is a shocking and appalling attack
which will reverberate around our
communities
and i want to take this opportunity
again to appeal to anybody who knows who
is responsible for this attack to please
come forward and give us those names
we need to find all who are responsible
for this
not just the gunman we need to find out
who supplied the weapon and who arranged
this terrible incident
forensic experts are at the scene at
this moment in time conducting house to
house inquiries
have taken place and offices are
reviewing cctv footage
to establish and identify who is
responsible
we will not rest until those who are
responsible are put behind bars
chief constable serena kennedy from
merseyside police speaking a little
earlier bringing us the details
surrounding olivia pratt corbell the
nine-year-old who was shot dead
yesterday confirming that police were
called at 10 o'clock in the night olivia
and her mother caught in a crossfire
yesterday she was shot in her home and
as you heard the from the chief
constable serena kennedy describing
yesterday's attack as shocking and
appalling attack which will reverberate
around our community so that's the
latest that's coming in from liverpool
there the nine-year-old who was shot
dead yesterday in her home has been
named as olivia pratt corbell we will
get more details later on and of course
we'll keep across that for you here on
sky news